בעוד שמחשבים קוונטיים לא יתאימו לפתרון
כל הבעיות, יש כמה סוגי בעיות
ומקרי שימוש פוטנציאליים שבהם אנחנו מצפים
שמחשוב קוונטי יהיה בעל השפעה.
אלה כוללים סימולציה כמו
מידול תהליכים ומערכות שמתרחשים ב
טבע, חיפוש ואופטימיזציה
שכוללים חיפוש אחר הפתרון הטוב ביותר או
האופטימלי במצב עם
הרבה תשובות אפשריות, ומתמטיקה
ועיבוד נתונים עם מבנה מורכב
כולל יישומים ללמידת מכונה.
אלגוריתמים קוונטיים לוקחים גישה חדשה ל
סוגי הבעיות האלה, תוך ניצול
התכונות הייחודיות של הפיזיקה הקוונטית כמו
סופרפוזיציה, הפרעה והסתבכות.
מחשבים רגילים נתקעים
בחקירת אזורים מסוימים של מרחב החישוב
אז הם לא יכולים למצוא את הדפוסים האלה.
מחשבים קוונטיים מצוידים ב
יכולות נוספות או ביצועים משופרים
לחלק מהבעיות בזכות הטבע הקוונטי שלהם.
כדי להבין לגמרי את הפוטנציאל של מחשבים קוונטיים
צריך לצלול לעומק לתורת המורכבות החישובית,
ענף במדעי המחשב שמתמקד ב
מדידה והשוואה של המאמץ החישובי ש
נדרש לפתרון סוגים שונים של בעיות.
זה מספק מסגרת שימושית
לתיאור האצות מהירות שונות
וסוגי בעיות שנתקלים בהם ב
מחשוב.